[Music]
since its launch in december 2021 nasa's
james webb space telescope has
successfully reached and surpassed a
number of important milestones in launch
arrival and configuration the mirrors
and instruments are being cooled and
calibrated over the telescope's first
six months in space in preparation for
science operations
so far it's either right on or even
ahead of schedule for everything this
incredible piece of machinery carries
the hopes and dreams of all astronomers
equipped with the largest and most
advanced telescope science has to offer
jwst will usher in a new era of
astronomy for the likes of you and me
now while the telescope is still very
early into its mission and has yet to
make any groundbreaking observations
these terrific and amazing first images
captured by the jwst give us a taste of
what this telescope is truly capable of
the image with the james webb space
telescope fully operational we have its
first ever perfect image the photo shows
a spiky image of a far away star
photobombed by thousands of ancient
galaxies the 10 billion telescope
successfully aligned with its near
infrared camera nir cam and took its
first ever clear image keep in mind that
this image released on march 16th from
the james webb space telescope is a test
shot not an official science observation
it is meant to see how the 18 hexagonal
mirrors work together for a single
coordinated image taken 1 million miles
away from earth and well it worked even
better than expected to non-astronomy
fans this may seem like a fairly average
image of the stars but let me explain to
you why this image is so much more than
it leads on firstly as you can tell the
centerpiece of the image is this very
bright star with what seems to be six
spikes coming out of it well the spikes
are an indication of how bright this
particular star is the spikes are
similar to a glare on a photo which is
nothing new what is new is everything
else in the background light pollution
doesn't only affect us here on earth but
the telescope's in space as well if any
other telescope were to look at this
bright star the light from this star
would drown out everything else in the
image but not for webb the jwst uses an
infrared camera to capture images you
see the jwst isn't just a big telescope
it's designed to ignore light pollution
it's meant to see even the dimmest of
lights in the distance so while any
other telescope would just see the
bright star jwst sees the bright star
and everything else it's hiding behind
that's what makes this image so amazing
these aren't just a cluster of stars and
galaxies these are a cluster of stars
and galaxies that we've never seen
before the light captured from these
galaxies is billions of years old what's
even crazier is that this image wasn't
really meant to be studied over the
course of three months the jwst has been
calibrating its telescope it's a long
and meticulous process this image was
taken with the purpose of calibration
sure we can study it in depth but it was
really just meant to test the cameras
and now that we have everything aligned
and fine-tuned the real fun begins
the next time a photo is released from
the jwst it will be a photo with intent
a specific galaxy or star that nasa has
an interest in when that comes our way a
plethora of questions and observations
will surely follow oh but don't think
i'm done blowing your mind yes the
galaxies in the background are amazing
and ancient but the star itself is just
as new to us as the galaxies scientists
said they were giddy as they watched the
latest test photos arrive do you know
why that test image was aimed at a star
100 times fainter than the human eye can
see 2 000 light years away for clarity a
light year is nearly 6 trillion miles
this bright star is actually one of the
faintest stars in the night sky we can't
see it here on earth it's barely
observable with any other telescope but
here we have the james webb making it
look as bright as the sun imagine just
how much more we can see now if this
little faint corner of the sky appears
to be this clear we haven't even begun
to map out the sky it's hard to
comprehend just how much we'll be able
to see by the end of webb's mission
eventually scientists hope webb will see
so far away and back in time that it
will be only a couple hundred million
years after the big bang in terms of
astronomy that's practically in the same
decade as the start of the universe the
actual scientific images won't come to
us till late june or early july when
those images begin to roll in the real
study of exoplanets in ancient galaxies
will start and boy am i excited
more to come while this stunning picture
has gotten the scientific community
giddy with excitement the work is still
not done the observatory still has four
other instruments that it must be able
to switch between with perfect alignment
to obtain sharp images of distant
objects next the guiding instrument
called the fine guidance sensor or fgs
needs to be deployed and then extend to
the other three instruments
on march 17th nasa's web engineers
stated that this process called
multi-instrument multi-field alignment
will take six weeks to complete
webb should complete its commissioning
period around june six months after
launching on december 25th
and while switching between cameras in
space is difficult and complicated the
telescope will eventually be able to use
multiple instruments at the same time it
may seem like an absurdly long time to
calibrate such a high-tech piece of
machinery but you have to keep in mind
that ground-based telescopes have the
advantage of having engineers available
on site to potentially remove or adjust
instruments however on web and other
space telescopes the procedure is very
different everything happens remotely so
things take much longer to complete and
fine-tune
fear not summer will be here soon enough
and will really be in business the fgs
already reached its own milestone
recently finishing fine guide mode this
occurs when the guider zeroes in on a
guide star to the instrument's highest
possible precision
additionally engineers are taking dark
images to see what happens when the
instrument has no light reaching it
which allows personnel to calibrate the
instrument even further the last
instrument to be aligned will be the mid
infrared instrument or the miri as it is
awaiting a cryogenic cooler's ability to
bring it to its operating temperature of
minus 448 degrees fahrenheit or minus
267 degrees celsius when everything is
up and running images like this will be
a common achievement by the james webb
space telescope
what do you think do you have anything
in particular you want the jwst to zoom
in on the possibilities are limitless